diese nachricht machte angst noch in
dieser woche sei ein einmarsch der
russen in die ukraine möglich so sahen
es die us geheimdienste heute gab es
aber eine andere bewegung teile der
russischen truppen die sollen abgezogen
worden sein die ankündigung die kam
passend zum antrittsbesuch von
bundeskanzler scholz bei präsident putin
es geht um krieg oder frieden in europa
an alte freund und feindschaften kann
deutschland vermitteln und auf wen ist
in diesem kräftemessen verlassen scholz
bei putin kriegsgefahr gebannt unser
thema heute in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
[Musik]
das will ich doch sagen für meine
generation ist krieg in europa und
denkbar geworden und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass das so bleibt es ist unsere
verdammte pflicht und aufgabe als staats
und regierungschefs zu verhindern dass
es in europa zu einer kriegerischen
eskalation kommt so bundeskanzler schoss
heute mittag bei der pressekonferenz in
moskau schönen guten abend hier aus
berlin ja was konnte scholz erreichen
und was gesteht putin zu darüber spreche
ich mit diesen gästen herzlich
willkommen harald kujat
generalinspekteur der ehemalige
vorsitzende des nato militärausschusses
und ich begrüße gemma pörzgen er sie ist
chefredakteurin der zeitschrift ost west
europäische perspektiven aufgewachsen in
moskau und in bonn denn ihr vater war
korrespondent in russland und sehr gut
dem vorstand von reporter ohne grenzen
an und ganz herzlich willkommen an
rehburg auf er ist russland experte der
deutschen welle sein vater wiederum war
sowjetische korrespondent in der ddr ist
aufgewachsen in ost berlin und moskau
und herzlich willkommen friedbert
pflüger unternehmensberater ehemaliger
cdu politiker er war auch mal
staatssekretär im
verteidigungsministerium stein guten
abend der flüge
genannt herr kujat jetzt sind nach
diesem jahr ankündigung die in dieser
woche für alle wirklich besorgnis hatten
und dachten am mittwoch wird dieser
einmal stattfinden und heute dieser
diese ankündigung des teilweisen
truppenabzugs ist die gefahr gebannt
die fähigkeit zu einem angriff die
besteht natürlich weiter die russischen
kräfte die dafür erforderlich sind sind
nach wie vor vor allem die frage ist ob
russland tatsächlich die absicht hat die
ukraine an anzugreifen nicht dafür sehe
ich im augenblick keine belege und der
abzug der
einesteils jedenfalls der truppen der
ist natürlich sehr elegant terminiert
worden um zu beweisen dass die
amerikanische informationen dich richtig
ist das ist ein ko putins offensichtlich
und ich hoffe dass er auch in amerika
verstanden werden und war es ist auch so
eine art geschenk für den antrittsbesuch
von olaf scholz kann man das so auch
sehr strategisch ich würde wenn ich die
pressekonferenz noch mal revue passieren
das würde ich das nicht so sehen
okay sagt hat es wäre ein einstich
richtung amerika natürlich ja der
amerikanische präsident hat sich heute
auch noch geäußert dazu kommen wir
später frau plötzlich wie haben sie das
empfunden diese nachricht heute und
diese pressekonferenz sind wir sozusagen
ein schritt wieder richtung deeskalation
gegangen ich glaube das ist zu früh das
zu sagen weil wir wissen ja eigentlich
noch gar nicht genau was da passiert
also man muss erst mal schauen was wer
zieht er eigentlich genau ab und was
verändert sich und wir hatten ja
irgendwie doppeldeutige signale aus
moskau wenn sie denken an die duma
entscheidung die es ja auch gab am
gleichen tag die separatisten gebiete
anzuerkennen das ist etwas was in kiew
jedoch mit großer sorge aufgenommen
wurde insofern finde ich fand vorher
erstaunlich dass der ton so hysterisch
war und man dachte morgen geht zu sagen
jetzt weiter der dritte weltkrieg los
aber jetzt würde ich doch sehr davor
warnen zu glauben das sei jetzt alles
vorbei ich glaube das würde diese fragen
werden uns auf jahre weiter beschäftigen
jahre okay gut der flüge wie haben sie
es empfunden bei der pressekonferenz und
dieser ankündigung dass da teile der
truppen abgezogen werden sind ja sind
sie jetzt etwas gucken sie etwas
hoffnungsvoller in dieses deutsch
russische verhältnis oder europäisch
russische verhältnisse
naja wir sehen jedenfalls allererste
anzeichen für eine gewisse entspannung
und wir haben ja einmal diesen
beginnenden abzug müssen wir nun sehen
was daraus im einzelnen folgt aber ich
fand die ganze tonlage und atmosphäre
dieses besuches sehr ermutigend ich fand
auch dass herr scholz das sehr gut
gemacht hat er ist ja hier von den
medien geradezu getrieben worden immer
mehr sollte erfordern immer stärkere
sanktionen auf den tisch bringen man hat
den führungslosigkeit vorgeworfen und
jetzt sehen wir doch dass er ganz
offenbar mit beiden marken sich in ruhe
abgestimmt hat und jetzt sehr nüchtern
sehr gelassen dort aufgetreten die am
vier stunden miteinander geredet das
heißt sie haben wirklich substanz
geredet und ich glaube schon dass das
jetzt heute vielleicht ein anfang einer
entspannung ist da wird auch vieles
besprochen worden sein was noch nicht an
den medien gekommen ist und was macht
man zum beispiel in der energie und
klima zusammenarbeit in der zukunft was
macht man positiv in die zukunft hinein
welche gemeinsamen projekte hat man dass
man mal weg von dieser eskalation von
forderungen und drohungen und wieder
eine positive okay aber die sehen erste
anzeichen in einer positiven richtung
herr gurov würden sie das teilen oder
ist es nur sozusagen wieder ein
stückchen
machtpoker um sozusagen den westen dann
ein bisschen an der langen leine jetzt
wieder laufen zu lassen
ich würde das etwas anderes sehen ich
bin völlig einverstanden mit frau
ausgehen dass das noch lange zeit
vielleicht jahre dauern wird das problem
aber ich habe in meiner meinung nach ein
wendepunkt an diesem wochenende gesehen
und der bestand darin putin hat geprüft
wollte vom westen bestimmte
zugeständnisse haben und hat den
eindruck erweckt dass er ein krieg
bereit es vom zaun zu brechen er hatte
ich glaube schon keine absicht
tatsächlich einen krieg zu machen
spekuliert aber darauf dass der westen
panische angst eben vor einem krieg hat
und in dieser situation hat es an diesem
wochenende meiner meinung nach eine
entscheidende aktion der in erster linie
der amerikaner gegeben die ihre
botschaft in kiew erschlossen sie nach
verlegten
dann kann die meldungen sie verbrennen
der dokumente alle ausländer nicht nur
die amerikaner auf die europäer wurden
ausgeflogen oder ausgefahren aus der
ukraine
das war ein völlig neues hartes zeichen
an moskau du versuchst uns angst
einzujagen mit einer bereitschafts krieg
zu führen wir sind bereit fernblieb lege
los verleiht dem er am 16 und wir haben
ein riesen koffer von sanktionen die wir
dann sofort einführen und ich glaube das
war der wendepunkt wodurch putin gesagt
hat 'jetzt muss sich die strategie
ändern und da war ausgerechnet und das
war sehr gut der besuch des kanzlers
weil er ohne gesichtsverlust sozusagen
die diplomatie wieder ins spiel bringen
sollte also ich glaube in den letzten 48
stunden
zwei drei tagen hat sich die situation
auch wenn vielleicht nur wenige soldaten
abgezogen sind von der stimmung her
grundsätzlich geändert aber erdmassen er
dass er und die bereitschaft des westens
zu spüren bekommen das sehen sie
erwarten also ja es gab schon bei besuch
markus ganz andere töne dass das auch
micro hat ja mit putin sehr lange
verhandelt und was wir aus diesen
gesprächen gehört haben das ist ja in
etwa deckungsgleich mit dem was wir aus
den gesprächen putins
bundeskanzler gehört haben was was
darauf hindeutet auch wie herr flüge
eben schon betont hat dass sich
offensichtlich mal krank und der
bundeskanzler vorher abgestimmt haben
und das finde ich sehr gut das ist dann
ein ganz wichtiger schritt dass wir
europäer eben größeren einfluss auf die
entwicklung dieser dinge bekommen ich
sehe das nicht dass am wochenende an
eine wende eingetreten ist sondern ich
sehe dass durch die gespräche präsent
markus und des bundeskanzlers größere
klarheit
entstanden ist was tatsächlich die
position russlands ist und wie weit er
bereit ist auch zu in den verhandlungen
zu gehen in beiden gesprächen ist ja
deutlich geworden dass putin weiter auf
verhandlungen setzt auch jetzt im
gespräch mit dem bundeskanzler das finde
ich sind ermutigende zeichen okay sie
sehen also sie sehen auf beiden seiten
unter den willen zum frieden ich sehe
nicht den willen zum frieden ist sie
zunächst mal nur den willen zu
verhandlungen okay und ich hoffe dass
diese verhandlungen dann auch zu einem
interessenausgleich führen im übrigen
hat präsent beiden genau das gleiche
heute abend betont auch er hat noch
einmal ganz deutlich gesagt wir sind
zwar bereit
zu reagieren für den fall eines angriffs
aber wir setzen auf diplomatie wir
setzen auf verhandlungen das hi hat auch
gesagt die nato ist keine bedrohung wir
wollen russland nicht
stabilisieren die dass die frage der
nato gerade der nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine ist aber für putin ja immer noch
ein ganz großes problem hören wir mal in
einen o ton von der pressekonferenz von
wladimir putin zu diesem punkt
wir hören
die ukraine nicht bereit ist jetzt der
nato beizutreten erkennen und sofort
wird gesagt dass morgen die ukraine
nicht aufgenommen wird sondern es wird
die ukraine erst dann aufgenommen wenn
sie vorbereitet sein wird aber für uns
kann es ja schon zu spät sein deshalb
wollen wir jetzt diese frage lösen also
unmittelbar jetzt in der nächsten zeit
im zuge des verhandlungsprozesses mit
friedlichen mitteln davon gehen sie raus
und wir hoffen sehr darauf dass unsere
sorge von unseren partner gehört werden
und auch ernst genommen werden alle das
entsorgen so nennt putin ist dass die
ukraine mitglied der nato werden könnte
und ihm reicht es nicht mehr das heißt
jetzt ist es nicht so weit weil er denkt
dann kommt dann später frau portman ist
das verständlich und ist es ein
sicherheitsrisiko für große land wenn
die ukraine mitglied der nato da ist
immer die frage wie man das sieht also
aus der russischen sicht ist es
natürlich eine schlüsselfrage also da
war immer klar dass sozusagen eine nato
mitgliedschaft der ukraine für moskau
nicht akzeptabel ist
insofern ist es aber eigentlich ja
irgendwie eine ganz komische diskussion
weil es steht ja auch gar nicht zur
debatte das leben kann mitglied werden
kann sondern das ist sozusagen ein
wunsch natürlich der ukrainischen
regierung und wie wir sehen ist es auch
so dass umfragen ja zeigen dass in der
ukrainischen bevölkerung inzwischen
dieser wunsch sogar gewachsen ist sofern
hat putin da eben auch eigentlich das
gegenteil von dem bewirkt politisch was
er eigentlich erreichen wollte weil
nämlich die nato sehr viel mehr noch ein
sehnsuchtsort geworden ist für viele
ukraine und ich glaube hat der russen
bitte mit ausnahme der russin die an
diesen abstimmungen nicht beteiligt
worden
diese sprachige menschen in der ukraine
die waren beteiligt und natürlich aus
der staatsbürger sind der der ukraine
der sohn wollte ich nur korrigieren ist
keine russische nation wir müssen glaube
ich deutlich machen dass die
abstimmungen zu dem zeitpunkt als die
russischen bürger in der ukraine mit
abgestimmt haben anders aus als heute wo
sie nicht mit abstimmt dass das muss man
glaube ich deutlich machen ja aber worum
es geht ist ja eine stimmung also das
ist ja sie sehen ja auch in anderen oder
nach schweden und in finnland das
sozusagen länder die neutral gewesen
sind bisher darüber nachdenken in die
nato zu gehen also ich glaube dass an
dieser darf sich etwas entwickelt und da
hat putin sozusagen eine missachtung der
flieger herr pfleger vielleicht sie auch
ihre einschätzung zu diesem punkt nato
mitgliedschaft der ukraine
es ist ich glaube in der tat dass es für
russland ein ganz wichtiger punkt ist
aber im westen ist kein verantwortlicher
politiker für einen nato-beitritt der
ukraine
das muss man putin auch klar sagen wir
haben ich bin ein großer freund der nato
erweiterung oder der nato öffnung wie
wir besser sagen immer gewesen in meiner
bundestags zeit habe immer gesagt das
ist wichtig damit wir kein zwischen
europa haben das unruhig ist es auch im
russischen interesse aber es war immer
klar bei der ukraine geht das nicht da
ist es zu nah an russland bei der ganzen
historischen erfahrung mit dem ersten
weltkrieg dem zweiten weltkrieg
napoleons einmarsch karl der zwölfte aus
schweden hat es versucht russland an
zugreifen können die russen gar nicht
anders und zwar jeder russische
präsident ob putin oder ob es irgendein
liberaler wäre jeder russische präsident
behaupte ich wäre da gästen ist auch
wenn die nato sich so weit nach vorne
vielleicht da wird das noch sagen ich
glaube wir haben immer dann gesagt das
geht auch deshalb nicht weil die ukraine
territorialkonflikte hat die dann direkt
in die nato hineingetrieben wird es also
dass krim thema zb welche ukraine würden
wir dann aufnehmen mit acryl oder ohne
die krim und dann geben wir eine
sicherheitsgarantie das ist ja der sinn
der nato eine sicherheitsgarantie zu
geben dann auch für das krim thema dann
haben wir den krieg in der nato dass es
nicht mehr stabilität sondern dass das
sind stabilität und ich kann nur sagen
die die ukraine werden klug beraten
einfach anzuerkennen ist schwer für sie
sie möchten gern in den autos verstehe
ich habe
mein nachbar ja sie sind nun mal nachbar
eines großen mächtigen landes dass wir
jede andere großmacht darauf achtet dass
ihr
vorhof sozusagen
sicher bleibt trotzdem die frage stellt
sich darauf ein dass
es gibt ja nur mal die nato am sonntag
sind ein land das
als er ein land von mehr als 40
millionen einwohnern die ukraine als
vorhof zu bezeichnen ist meines
erachtens nach ziemlich erniedrigend für
eine selbstständige souveräne
europäische rat nation also ich würde
nicht nur sehr ungern in der sozusagen
mit solchen termin hier diskutieren wie
das ein vorhof ein land irgendwo in
europa irgendwelchen der vorwurf hast
da wird man sagen dass das würde ich
gerne dadurch gerne reagieren die
ukraine ist ein
wunderbares großes mir sehr nahe
liegendes land ich wünsche mir eine
starke unabhängige demokratische ukraine
der begriff vorhof oder bäcker heute
würden die amerikaner sagen der ist nur
in der internationalen politik und in
der politikwissenschaft geläufig das
heißt einfach dass eine großmacht sagt
ich möchte in meiner umgebung lich
krisenherde haben
die amerikaner seit 1823 immer gemacht
und das ist das recht oder das ist macht
man bedauern oder auch nicht aber es ist
die realität im internationalen
ja ich finde diese diskussion über
einflusssphären die sie ja da beginnen
herr pflüger nicht besonders hilfreich
weil ich das gefühl habe wir drehen uns
darüber um bestimmte fragen die wir
jetzt in den letzten wochen immer wieder
gehört haben
wichtiger ist doch jetzt in dem jetzigen
moment mehr darüber nachzudenken wie
soll das denn in zukunft aussehen also
wie können wir sprechen über eine
ukraine und deren zukunft und wie
kriegen wir das irgendwo zu sagen hin
diese unterschiedlichen interessen
auszubalancieren weil das schon klar
geworden ist putin hat ja sehr viel
erreicht in der letzten woche ging hat
er auch klare forderungen auf den tisch
gelegt genau eine klare forderungen auf
den tisch gelegt über die man weiter das
mädchen muss aber was ich noch sagen
wollte ist er hat auch erreicht dass er
eben jetzt wieder in der diskussion ist
nicht also wir haben dieses thema ja
über viele jahre einfach auch
vernachlässigt in der also zum beispiel
fand ich einen schwachpunkt in der sonst
interessanten pressekonferenz bei herrn
scholz dass er davon sprach wir wollen
keinen krieg irgendwie in europa den
gibt es ja längst nicht wir haben seit
acht jahren krieg in der ukraine
und wir haben wie zu wenig dafür getan
den zu beenden und die quittung haben
wir jetzt bekommen
und ich glaube wir sollten diese chance
ergreifen jetzt tatsächlich einfach ganz
neu zu diskutieren und nicht in meinem
diesen alten muss dann über wer hat
fehler gemacht war ist die nato
osterweiterung aber wer nicht eine
gelungene außerdem um neu zu diskutieren
erklärt wäre das nicht eine wirklich
vollständige abzug also vielleicht sagen
sie es auch nochmal aus ihrer
militärischen sich was bedeutet das
eigentlich wenn der 100000 soldaten
stehen wie gefährlich ist es und könnte
die nato da wirklich eigentlich was
gegen ausreden tja da die daten
jetzt dran und die nato muss ja dagegen
gar nichts ausrichten die ukraine ist
nicht mitglied der nato
welche wir haben überhaupt keine
verpflichtungen gegenüber der ukraine
die einzige verpflichtung die wir
präsent beiden ausdrücklich gesagt wir
werden keine amerikanischen soldaten für
den fall eines angriffs in der ukraine
zum schutz der ukraine einsetzen völlig
richtig die alte das einzige interesse
dass wir im zusammenhang mit der ukraine
krise haben ist das aus dem konflikt mit
der ukraine kein konflikt um die ukraine
wird also zwischen nato und russland
und was die frage der nato
mitgliedschaft der ukraine betrifft die
dann muss sollten wir uns doch
vielleicht mal darauf beschränken auf
das was die rechtslage uns sagt und die
rechtslage sagt uns und
interessanterweise hat präsident putin
exakt das zitiert sagt uns die ukraine
kann gar nicht mitglied der nato werden
sie kann es nicht weil sie nicht die
voraussetzungen erfüllt aber erklärt es
ist eine viel engere angeschaut
auch sie kennen sie den sicherheit
garantieren für die ukraine ankommt wer
kommen hat er drauf da komme ich es
können aber es muss ja wirklich glaube
wir ein bisschen mit der ukraine ehrlich
auch umgehen wir dürfen nicht sagen die
ukraine wir machen jetzt ein moratorium
die ukraine verzichtet auf die
mitgliedschaft die ukraine kann nicht
auf der bühne stehen sich leverkusen
müsste man dann nicht ganz klar sagen
sie wird nicht mitglied der nato
in richtung
eine ruhige das will ich jetzt aber
nicht was wir nicht tun können ist
natürlich ein völkisches verbindliches
abkommen über die nichtmitgliedschaft
der ukraine mit russland schließen aber
was wir tun können ist dass wir sagen
wir haben die wir 30 mitgliedsstaaten
der nato die im konsens die ukraine
einladen müssten haben nicht die absicht
sie ihr die mitgliedschaft anzubieten
wir haben nicht die absicht sie
einzuladen dania haben wir sozusagen ein
türöffner lassen sie mich noch
vielleicht ihre frage woher und da
geht's lang weiter
vorhof ist hier der begriff gefallen ich
schließe mich an das an was henry
kissinger schon 2014 gesagt hat er hat
gesagt die ukraine darf nicht zu einem
vorposten
russlands gegen den westen werden sie
darf aber umgekehrt auch nicht zu einem
vorposten des westens gegenüber russland
werden die ukraine muss eine brücke
zwischen ost und west bilden und das
bedeutet sie sollte eine konsolidierte
neutralität haben das halte ich für
akzeptabel und das fällt natürlich
schwer wenn auf der anderen seite 100000
aber das feld überhaupt nicht viel
finden ist das auch nicht schwer aber
das derzeit nicht hunderttausende
soldaten auch immer russische soldaten
100 dollar oder 50.000 das spielt keine
rolle ob ich merke flügger sie möchten
sich noch äußern aber ich würde ganz
gerne erst noch kurz den kopf gehen im
moment davon über sofort ich wollte
gerne und nachhaltig weiß das ist immer
schlecht für die kollegen die
zugeschaltet sind aber herr gurov
vielleicht doch noch mal kurz die frage
wieso also wie sich dar wie wichtig ist
das für die ukraine diese nato
mitgliedschaft und wo sehen sie die
möglichkeit dass man sagt das kann
funktionieren wenn die ukraine die
neutral wird
also der kanzlei sich heute auch sehr
gewundert warum wir die ganze diskussion
über die mitgliedschaft der ukraine der
nato führen das steht überhaupt nicht
zur zeit ist in diskussion
was zur diskussion eigentlich stehen
müsste ist das ukrainische territorium
namentlich gekrümmt und ein teil des
ostens besetzt sind
die krim ist annektiert im osten der
ukraine sind
separatisten am werk das wird irgendwie
zumindest bei der jetzigen diskussion
heute abend irgendwie ausgelassen und
wir sprechen über
eine neutralität der ukraine damit sie
keine gefahr für russland darstellen ich
glaube wir sollten auch mal die frage
stellen eine frage die sich hier in
russland die nicht zahlreichen muss ich
leider zugeben demokraten stellen man
bekommt denn die ukraine die möglichkeit
seine territoriale integrität im osten
beispielsweise wiederherzustellen und
die jetzt gesagt wir haben eine
situation wo die ukraine gar nicht in
die nato kann weil sie kriegerisch
auseinanderhalten habe ich nicht gesagt
ist ja ein teil des konzeptes des kremls
ständig
das habe ich nicht
weil ich etwas dagegen gesagt darum eine
annäherung der ukraine an den westen an
die nato auch an die eu zu sabotieren
dieser komplex dieser fragenkomplex
kommt glaube ich viel zu wenig in der
diskussion zur sprache und was putins
interesse ist jetzt auf einmal dieses
thema hochkochen zu lassen und dieses
bestreben wir müssen jetzt sofort schon
so schnell wie möglich eine entscheidung
treffen es gibt in russland die ich das
beobachte bei den
politologen eine diskussion was bezweckt
er es gibt eine vorstellung dass er
versucht sozusagen
einflusssphären zu markieren es gibt da
auch die vorstellung dass seine
vorstellungen
bescheidener sind und dass er versucht
in dieser jetzigen situation eine
legitimierung der kremation zu erreichen
ok und wenn wir beispielsweise
lebens zwar schön war er in erinnerung
rufen in teilen der restlichen auch der
militärischen elite scheint diese stimme
vorhanden zu sein ja gut geben wir ihnen
die grünen dies weg und dann haben ja
nur oriental ist die ganze karwoche
heute gern gemacht worden ist auch
damit verbunden herr flieger wie sehen
sie es ist dass der dass der zentrale
punkt dass wir euch zu wenig über die
die krim reden auch über don was aber
all diese anderen gebiete und dass wir
da sozusagen uns schon daran gewöhnt
haben
ich glaube in der tat wir brauchen für
die ost ukraine eine diplomatische
lösung dafür haben wir das minsker
abkommen die verhandlungen im normandie
format man sollte aber vielleicht mal
nach anderen beispielen in der
geschichte gucken es gibt zum beispiel
den die lösung für südtirol die hat die
uno verhandelt in langen verhandlungen
die im grunde von 1945 bis 1992 gingen
und das ist praktisch eine natürlich
nicht in jedem punkt aber in manchen
punkten vergleichbare situation und
heute haben wir so
italien ist der souverän aber es gibt
weitgehende autonomie auch für die
südtiroler die nicht italiener von der
nationalität sind aber sich inzwischen
in diesem italienischen staatsverband
wohlfühlen und loyale staatsbürger
geworden sind wenn wir nach solchen
lösungen suchen wie die südtirol lösung
dann glaube ich kommen wir weiter und da
wollen wir müssen jetzt langsam da
möchte ich an das anknüpfen was frau
kurz gesagt hat lassen wir doch jetzt
mal diese sachen weg die russen müssen
ihre 120 tausend leute abziehen werden
sie
die nato auf
was wir jetzt machen
müssen ist wir müssen gemeinsame
projekte finden die wieder vertrauen
aufbauen
die klimapolitik
aber
nochmal wir wollen doch gerade mit der
anfrage von frau per scan dazu kommen
wie machen was in der zukunft
natürlich ist es völlig unakzeptabel
diese drohung mit 120.000 soldaten
plötzlich
lassen wir doch jetzt jetzt versuchen
wir mal in die zukunft zu gucken und da
wäre es doch fantastisch wenn wir die
enormen ressourcen der ukraine auch
russlands nutzen viel sonne viel wind
viel biomasse
wir könnten große aufforstungsprojekte
machen wasserstoff projekte machen
solarprojekte biomethan
möglichkeiten
ich bin so für eine für eine klimax cd
wir hatten sofort
sich eine rosige zukunft malen wollen
aber ich glaube dass wir hier
tatsächlich ein bisschen schief
diskutieren wir haben auch keine ukraine
krise so wie wir hier gerade irgendwie
reden sondern wir haben eine massive
russlandkrise mit der wir uns
beschäftigen müssen und die ist auch
deutlich geworden durchaus am heutigen
tag weil nämlich die position von herrn
scholz und herrn putin sehr weit
auseinander lagen auch wenn es im ton
ordentlich war wir keine klar erlebt
haben und es durchaus sozusagen ein
kleines anzeichen für entspannung gibt
möchte das gerne noch eben ausführen wir
haben aber ein sehr
positives russland in dem sozusagen
innenpolitisch alle kräfte die sozusagen
für die zukunft sich etwas anderes
vorstellen als herr putin unterdrückt
werden die medienfreiheit ist
eingeschränkt wir haben das verbot von
memorial erlebt also wir haben eine
massive russlandkrise von der ich glaube
dass wir keine adäquate antwort darauf
haben und haben jetzt massiv erlebt was
das bedeuten kann wenn russland eben ein
ist das bedauerlicherweise eben auch
militärische aktionen als mittel der
politik ansieht etwas was eigentlich im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert tabu sein
sollte und ich finde ein bisschen dass
wir uns nicht ernsthaft genug mit diesen
fragen beschäftigen sondern immer wieder
kreisen über diese endlosen diskussionen
nato rauskommen
also ehrlich gesagt wir müssen wirklich
uns mit dem beschäftigen was wir da
sehen und da ist er ja wenn ich einen
kurzen her schon so noch anfügen darf es
ist auch so dass belarus zum beispiel
unserer diskussion überhaupt nicht mehr
vorkommt dabei haben wir gerade gesehen
es ist ein aufmarschgebiet gewesen für
die russischen föderation die ukraine
ist eingekreist von allen seiten nicht
und werde es kann auch nicht sein dass
wir jetzt einfach sagen okay jetzt
hatten wir angst vor dem krieg und jetzt
kommt die entspannung sondern wir müssen
uns sehr sehr ernsthaft damit
beschäftigen wie gehen wir mit einem
russland um das anders als die
sowjetunion kein stabiler staat ist
sondern höchst instabil aber was der
pflege flüge er meinte die frage dann
der in zukunft sehr gut erleben dass man
schaut also
haben wir noch überhaupt keine gute
zukunft mal fehlt keine keine
glorifizieren will das nicht
glorifizieren aber wir haben schon mal
einen schlimmen kalten krieg gehabt mit
großen bedrohung und dann gab es eine
entspannungs politik und die muss man
schrittweise aufbauen da ist viel hass
da ist viel misstrauen und das müssen
wir jetzt ganz langsam wieder versuchen
in eine andere bahn zu lenken ein ganz
wichtiges einmal ein und 270 eine
entspannungs politik von willy brandt
gehabt und dann er hat sich daraus etwas
ergeben dann haben wir eine kfz gemacht
dann haben wir pläne gehabt wie wir
miteinander umgehen wie wir langsam
wieder zum beispiel versuchen militär
fonda hat sich nicht mehr durch fujitsu
da mal klar machen
dass sie nur über
würden sie denn es gibt ja dann ganz
konkrete dinge und eine sache die der
entspannung ja die wichtiges instrument
oder hindernis ist ist nord stream 2
auch darüber wurde heute wieder
gesprochen herr scholz hat ganz klar
gesagt dass er das herr schröder nicht
die meinung der deutschen regierung
vertritt aber es ist doch ein punkt der
strittig ist oder sie sagen es wäre
ganz offensichtlich ist das nicht mehr
strittig präsident biden hat heute ganz
klar gesagt vor einigen tagen schon beim
staatsbesuch ich stelle den ostring zwei
nicht in dienst und damit ist das ein
teil offensichtlich dass sanktionspaket
aber die frage ist doch wir haben eine
krise wie sie können sie nennen wie sie
wollen und wir müssen verhindern dass
habe ich vorhin schon gesagt dass aus
dieser krise ein krieg wird und zwar ein
europäischer krieg und an und dann erst
ich würde es gerne mal in zwei drei
sätzen erklären man kann das in drei
phasen abarbeiten die erste phase ist
die frage der ukraine und zwar in
doppelter hinsicht jetzt komme ich auf
auf
die die
den bass und die krim zu sprechen die
eine seite ist die innere verfasstheit
der der ukraine da gibt es ein bis zwei
abkommen und da sollten bis ende 2015
bestimmte maßnahmen durchgeführt werden
die sind nicht durchgeführt worden wären
sie durchgeführt worden hätten wir in
politisch eine relativ stabile lage
heute hat der bundeskanzler in der
pressekonferenz gesagt es gebe nun die
die gesetzgebung in der ukraine für eine
verfassungsreform und fortgesetzt wir
werden sehen ob es ob das der fall ist
wie die umgesetzt werden wenn das der
fall ist ist das ein deutlicher schritt
in richtung größerer entspannung die
zweite frage ist die welchen platz soll
die ukraine in zukunft in einer
europäischen sicherheitsarchitektur
haben soll sie nato mitglied sein soll
sie neutral sein oder soll dieser
schwebezustand in dem sich im augenblick
befindet aufrechterhalten bleiben und da
kann ich nur sagen wir müssen eine
lösung finden die zu wer größere
stabilität führt und da muss die ukraine
hat er noch mitarbeiten natürlich muss
die ukraine mitarbeiten aber den weg die
den himmel den henry kissinger
aufgezeigt hat den halte ich nach wie
vor für dankbar und ich wiederhole es
noch einmal es ist überhaupt keine frage
ob die ukraine in die nato will oder ob
sie nicht will entscheidend für putin
für russland ist sind diejenigen die
über den beitritt zu entscheiden haben
aber wenn es die wenn es diese garantie
gebe für putin würde sich dann etwas
ändern er als würde sich etwas inne wir
müssen einfach es wird immer gesagt die
ursache dieser krise ist der
truppenaufmarsch nein die uhr sa ist es
der anlass für diese krise die ursache
liegt im jahr 2008 und die liegt darin
dass damals präsident bush versucht hat
mit aller macht die mitgliedschaft der
ukraine
und georgiens im bukarester nato-gipfel
durchzusetzen die mehrheit der nato
staaten waren nicht bereit das zu
akzeptieren
aber der heutige start in oder russland
bedroht hat das war der wendepunkt im
verhältnis das müssen wir deshalb müssen
wir uns auch selbst einmal überlegen was
wir dazu beigetragen haben dass die
situation so ist wie sie heute ist okay
aber dann würde ich jetzt mal ganz
normal hingucker fragen was können wir
denn jetzt dazu beitragen dass die
situation sich wirklich ändert also wenn
wir jetzt sagen die truppen müssten
abgezogen werden das muss ein garten
garantie für die ukraine geben dass sie
nicht mitglied der mandate wird wäre
dann ihrer meinung nach wären das die
voraussetzungen wie man sagt okay dann
können wir haben wir wieder ein
entspanntes verhältnis zu sein kann man
über andere dinge sprechen das dürfen
wir nicht vergessen
[Musik]
ich wundere mich wieder dass hier der
von westlicher seite beziehungsweise von
den gesprächspartnern heute
vorgeschlagen wird die ukraine solle
unter dem massiven druck russlands
nachgeben die tatsache vergessen dass
ihr territorium abhanden gekommen sind
sagen wir
akzeptieren das was uns vorgeschlagen
wird gehen in die neutralität bekommen
aber dafür nichts
nicht unsere gebiete zurück weil man uns
und das ist das eigentlich erst wenn
sich chinesen heute realisiert worden
weil die separatisten territorium sollen
nach russischen plan so ich wie ich
heute sozusagen eingebaut werden in den
startlöchern ismus und seinen
staatsverband der ukraine und immer ein
stör mechanismus sein das ist ja das
problem warum das münchner abkommen das
damals 2015 sehr gut geholfen hat die
die blutige schlacht um gewalt sofort zu
beenden und einen gewissen frieden und
das morgen das morgen zu beenden und
einen gewissen frieden zu erzeugen aber
dieses menschen abkommen dass es das
problem bringt uns nicht weiter weil das
ist ein konzept das er gern einzel keine
sorgen weil der verfassung ein
wirklicher so sehen und hier glaube ich
ist die problematik hier müssen wir
ansetzen muss ja cool hier noch mal
widersprechen dann war ich gerne
sagen dass minsk kommen wird bedeutet
doch wenn es implementiert wird dass der
bass und die eu und die krippe bei der
ukraine bleiben das ist doch der sinn
die verfassungsreform
ist ja auch was rede ich eher zum auge
meist eine sonderzone
es ist doch nichts wenn da so ein
quatsch erzählt wird man muss den
vertrag x mal lesen in minsk
jetzt ist der kohl hat kurz daran bitte
es geht um eine verfassungsreform die
den teilen der ukraine in denen eine
russische mehrheit lebt eine größere
autonomie gewährt und das ich bin der
meinung die ukraine ist ein
vielvölkerstaat russen routinen polen
kurs sagten alles mögliche es ist
überhaupt notwendig dass die
minderheitenrechte in der ukraine
gestärkt werden und das würde damit
gemacht aber dann blieben natürlich
diese territorien bei der ukraine
das denn in ihre vorstellung diese
entscheidung der duma heute das ist
genau das gleiche wieder
truppenaufmarsch nur auf andere weise
okay ich würde gern die letzten
die letzten minuten in dieser sendung
das man nutzen um auf die rolle
deutschland zu schauen und auch die
frage nach diesem nach dem deutsch
russischen verhältnis wir haben heute
und dem kanzler gehabt mit seinem
antritt sich ein besuch es gab eine
menge
ärger vorher wir haben die deutsche
welle schon erwähnen memorial navalny
all diese punkte der mord im tiergarten
also frau b das verhältnis war ja nicht
besonders gut oder ist nicht besonders
gut was verstehen wir von einander
eigentlich nicht sie sind in beiden sie
kennen sich in beiden ländern gut aus ja
das ist gar nicht so einfach zu sagen
also ich bin tatsächlich im kalten krieg
groß geworden und hab das noch sehr gut
in erinnerung diese ganzen klischees und
stereotype wenn ich so nach deutschland
kam um eine riesige familie zu besuchen
und ich finde vieles von dem ist
natürlich wieder im raum und ich sehe
die große herausforderung und in der
hinsicht war ich zum beispiel ganz
glücklich heute mit diesem besuch von
herrn schoofs weil ich das gefühl habe
es war im stil und im umgang miteinander
sehr vernünftig und
trotzdem hat er klare worte gefunden zu
wichtigen themen ob nun nawal nähe oder
memorial
und ich glaube dass wir eben uns eben
einstellen müssen auf ein sehr
schwieriges russland und dazu gehört
aber auch dass man auf der einen seite
putin nicht dämonisiert das ist etwas
was ich zum beispiel gerade meine
eigenen branche mit sorge sehe dass wir
viele artikel haben bei denen dieses
ganze riesige land immer reduziert wird
auf irgendwelche analysen über putin
das wird uns nicht reichen sondern wir
müssen uns vielmehr beschäftigen mit der
verfasstheit der gesellschaft der
politik es gibt auch ganz viele andere
politiker nicht nur putin die bei uns
auch kaum vorkommen sozusagen
ein areal von boya aber es hat drei ring
einen großen mangel an expertise muss
man mal sagen ja und ich finde diese
krise sollte dazu uns helfen das zu
erkennen und da viel mehr auszubauen
weil ich glaube dass ist das einzige was
hilft dass wir wirklich wissen was in
diesem land vor sich geht es für
menschen haben die die sprache können
dass wir abgeordnete haben die nicht zum
ersten mal nach moskau reisen und auch
nicht nur die eine seite kennen sondern
sozusagen auch viele dieser
postsowjetischen staaten
und da sehe ich einen riesen mangel das
ist das was mich wirklich sehr bekümmert
ja also weil ich ja tatsächlich glaube
die herausforderung durch russland
bleiben groß und es wird nicht das
letzte mal sein dass wir solche
diskussion her der flieger wie würden
sie sehen was würden sie sich wünschen
im deutsch russischen verhältnis und
wenn sie heute den kanzler gesehen haben
ist das ein guter ton weil er hat ja
durchaus all die kritischen dinge auch
angesprochen
ja und das ist auch richtig sie
anzusprechen weil neben im moor real ich
war selbst beim memorial die haben tolle
arbeit geleistet in der aufarbeitung des
stalinismus und das für richtig dass er
das gemacht hat aber er hat etwas ganz
wichtiges gesagt er hat gesagt wir
können sicherheit in europa nie gegen
russland sondern immer nur mit russland
schaffen und ich glaube dass das ganz
wichtig dass wir bei unserer engen
einbindung in den westen unserer
bündnistreue der engen abstimmung mit
frankreich mit den usa immer auch als
anwalt eines guten verhältnisses
westlichen institutionen mit russland
auftreten als deutsche und ich finde das
hat eschholz gemacht in der tradition
aller bundesregierungen und ich kann nur
sagen wir sollten wir wirklich sehen wie
können wir mit kleinen schritten
mal da keine wunderbaren gemälde an die
wand mit kleinen schritten langsam
wieder vertrauen aufbauen und dazu war
das finde ich jetzt ein guter startpunkt
nochmal südtirol lösung keine
konsolidierte neutralität das stichwort
von einem kujat und henry kissingers
finde ich völlig richtig eine
neutralität heißt ja nicht dass man
nicht mit dem mit dem westen eng
verbunden sein soll das war in
österreich und finnland auch ist die
schweiz auch sondern da kann man eine
tolle rolle spielen und das wünsche ich
mir dass die ukraine diese rolle annimmt
und etwas für ihre minderheiten im osten
tut es die sich wohlfühlen in der
ukraine und dann auch loyale
staatsbürger gegenüber der ukraine
werden was ist das ziel
würden sie sich dann wünsch in diesem
deutsch russischen fans sie sind eben
auch in diesen beiden welten so groß
geworden wo merken sie was versteht man
immer voneinander nicht und wo muss man
sich da auch eine andere art annähern
und welche rolle kann deutschland auch
jetzt in diesem in diesem prozess dann
wieder vielleicht stärker spielen
also ich muss auch mit genugtuung
feststellen dass der heutige besuch
gelungen ist und es anscheinend so ein
dialog gekommen ist der ausbaufähig ist
aber ich will auch nicht das mantra
ständig im dialog bleiben dieses mantra
das wiederholt wird und man beruhigt
sich auch sehr gut das memorial und
neuwahlen
angesprochen sind man hat sozusagen sein
gewissen gereinigt das ist kein vorwurf
an scholz wunderbar dass er das gemacht
hat aber das reicht nicht auch nicht für
die generell die deutsche gesellschaft
da muss mehr kommen mehr unterstützung
für die immer mehr unter druck geraten
die demokratische bewegung kann man gar
nicht sagen wie wir demokratischen
kreise in russland
es muss aber auch sicherlich
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit gefördert
werden und da gibt es ansatzpunkte und
es ist jammerschade dass die ganze
bandbreite der möglichkeiten der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit auf die
nord stream zwei reduziert worden ist
natürlich kein wirtschaftliches und kein
rein wirtschaftlich das sondern in
erster linie an geopolitisches projektes
irgendwann muss dieses kapitel in
irgendeiner form gelöst werden und dann
sollte man so wirklich
wirtschaftlichen
zusammenarbeit über gehen ohne zu
vergessen dass russland ein immer
autoritärer werden der staat wird wird
man bei all den politischen
wirtschaftlichen entscheidungen
berücksichtigt würden sie denn sagen
dass schröder da hilfreich war oder
gerade nicht in dieser zusammen an
diesem zusammenhang nein definitiv nicht
definitiv nicht okay
fotos die nach etwas was würden sie sich
wünschen wo sagen sie muss man ansetzen
dass sich das deutsch russische
verhältnis dass das besser wird und dass
deutschland da ja auch in eine zentrale
position hat und das erste deutsch
russische verhältnis ist ein element des
verhältnisses des westens mit russland
es ist kein isoliertes verhältnis sein
fell ist es eingebettet in das
verhältnis der europäischen union zu
russland und der nato zu russland
deshalb würde ich mir wünschen dass die
bundesregierung nun endlich die nato
dazu bringt den prozess der
verhandlungen fortzuführen mit russland
denn das was ich geschildert habe im
hinblick auf die ukraine ist ja nur der
erste schritt das ist der türöffner
danach müssen in einem zweiten schritt
die strategischen fragen abgearbeitet
werden zum beispiel die stationierung
von nato truppen auf dem gebiet der
neuen mit diesen baltischen staaten
polen und so weiter und in einem dritten
schritt müssen dann endlich die
abrüstung und rüstungskontrolle
verhandlung beginnen an erster stelle
die 33 verträge die von den vereinigten
staaten in den letzten jahren gekündigt
wurden und dann vertrauensbildende
maßnahmen mehr transparenz mehr
vorhersehbarkeit des politischen
handelns rasmus erreicht okay ich sehe
man immer dass sich auf
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen das war
heute wahrscheinlich eine diese frösche
oder dieses treffen von scholz und putin
vielen dank für die diskussion herr coco
für flüge er kreiert und fresken vielen
dank infos zu schonen und das interesse
es geht hier gleich weiter mit phoenix
der tag und michael krons und da geht
dann durch nochmal ausführlich auch um
diese pressekonferenz aus denen wir
ihnen ja ausschnitte schon gezeigt haben
morgen ist wieder eine phoenix runde und
dann reden wir mal wieder über corona
maßnahmen bis dann